[Applause]
so you've met everybody now and you can
also have some wine why are you guys so
far away
okay but yes thank you cheers to that
cheers
thank you I'm not gonna leave you
hanging oh well now
come back to it or bad luck or something
okay so you were just 12 when you
started performing that's crazy yes like
is it how has life changed since then
obviously were you was it kind of crazy
hard when you were 12. I mean I don't
remember much before that oh wow you
know yeah 12 yeah yeah you know what I
don't either when people ask about your
child I don't remember that do you
remember when you were like 11 not
really yeah yeah moments moments the
ones that you maybe write songs about
yeah yeah yes yeah so what kind of music
did you grow up with I grew up listening
to actually Lauren a lot of powerful
female artists yeah thank you obviously
um the first album I bought was Lauren
Hill's album Miss education
that was one of my I bought that for
myself and you know Beyonce's first
album Erica Badu oh Missy Elliott Little
Kim wow yes very strong woman I know you
like a strong woman I like that too
that's cool me too I love it what did
y'all grow up what did you grow up with
in Mexico City what was real big
whenever you're growing uh pop music
what we have a lot of influence from the
US a lot yeah but uh we also hear like
uh while my actual wife she's a popular
singer in Mexico so that's it you've got
to say her then don't not say her her
my wife this is the cue where you say
her her Alessandra rosaldo oh that's so
cool that's awesome what did you listen
to her on everything girl ever read me I
mean Lauren Hill to the foods you used
to like I mean so like Annie Linux
everyone and everyone Aretha yeah
everyone yeah I feel like we all like
such cool people when we were younger to
listen to I don't know does everybody
feel like that I don't know
um so well John Malkovich is on your
album I find that crazy how what kind of
happenstance was that that he ended up
on your album so peteburg invited me to
be a part of his movie called mile 22
and we were acting together and you know
whenever time off we had he was just
talking about his stories from theater
and connected and he's my mentor now
here I love that
[Applause]
that Mike Tyson was an inspiration with
this album please tell me how you know
he's doing these podcasts these days I'm
a fan of him oh I didn't know that yeah
and I was just going through his
podcasts and some of the things he said
things like before I you know fight how
he feels I connected to that oh do you
see the stage as a boxing arena uh you
know I think it's just about the gap
between you know the emotions you use on
stage and off stage yeah do you kind of
become my mother always laughs at me
because she's like I can tell it's like
literally right when I finish the song
then I become like the bubbly yes me off
stage yes but during the song I'm like
very in the zone yeah I like that as
well yes we all have a Sasha face we all
do and that's what Alpha is about are my
albums so I love that that's why you
titled that yes I love that is that
where you feel the most powerful like in
like on stage yeah I call like I'm a
performer so that's where I feel
comfortable and that's why I love doing
yeah I love your Vibe I was watching
while I was getting ready today and I
was watching rehearsals and I was like
oh my God I did I was watching and I was
like I was like oh my gosh and all the
dancing it's so cool it's very very cool
I'm doing it and I love it too because
it starts off and you're like I don't
want to run it anyway I like the whole
performance
um but you went to the speaking of like
how artistic you looked you went to the
Met Gala this year was that so yes I did
it was I love playing dress-ups so I had
fun yeah yeah oh you enjoy it yes I love
doing it I love I love this by the way
I'm from Texas so this is so Texas this
is like how Texas Americana so okay
that's why there was a jeans and you
know the I was wearing underwear I love
that good for you
[Laughter]
no that was a part of the dress but yeah
yeah
um but it was cool because I heard it
was an Asian designer right yes it was
Alexander Wang and you know it did not
look like that in the beginning but I
wanted to make sure I melt my culture in
there so yeah we had to change it in 24
hours we he made a completely new us and
wow the bow is actually a traditional
Korean yeah that's cool
somebody makes but then you fertilize it
yes like the people
people that's like my favorite thing
that's where the magic happens yeah
that's so cool I love that you're into
it all that's cool
um well you're performing um your song
Lover like me so what's that one about
other than maybe possibly being a lover
like you
well it's you know I'm just talking to
my ex oh I love telling him yeah you
will never ever find a lover like me
yeah I love I love that kind of
empowering statement especially if
you're like after a breakup and you've
like so many people are going to relate
to that message yeah it's just like you
know time when you're brushing it off
yeah listen to that song you'll be like
yes yeah yes I love you
[Music]
thank you